La théorie du Big Bang est un des
grands monuments de la physique moderne
et aujourd'hui plus aucun cosmologiste
ne remet en cause ses fondements
et pourtant comme pour toute théorie scientifique nouvelle,
les débuts n'ont pas été si simples.
Si elle a été imaginée à la fin des années 1920,
la théorie du Big Bang a été initialement
assez controversée et critiquée
et ce n'est qu'à partir des années 60 qu'elle
s'est imposée comme étant LA meilleure théorie
pour décrire le passé et les origines de l'Univers.
Tout ça, grâce à une découverte qui fût
un argument extrêmement puissant
en faveur de la théorie du Big Bang:
le rayonnement cosmologique.
♫ [[ Musique générique ]] ♪
Je ne vais pas vous faire un épisode sur les détails
de la théorie du Big Bang, ça sera pour une autre fois,
mais l'essentiel à savoir, c'est qu'on vit
dans un Univers qui est en expansion,
c'est-à-dire que la plupart des galaxies
s'éloignent les unes des autres.
A partir de l'observation du mouvement des galaxies
et grâce aux équations de la cosmologie,
il est possible de rembobiner le film de l'histoire de l'Univers.
Ces calculs nous montrent que, plus on remonte
dans le temps, plus l'Univers était dense et chaud
et d'après les équations, il y a 13,8 milliards d'années,
l'Univers était même tellement dense et tellement chaud
que toute la physique que l'on connait y était bouleversée.
Dans les années 40, alors que la théorie du Big Bang
était loin de faire l’unanimité parmi les scientifiques,
les physiciens se sont dit que si l'Univers
avait été effectivement si chaud dans le passé,
il devait bien en rester des traces quelque part,
une sorte de vestige.
Notamment, il faut savoir que si ce scénario est correct,
la matière, à l'époque des premiers instants du Big Bang,
n'était pas dans l'état qu'on lui connait actuellement.
Déjà, il n'y avait que deux éléments,
de l'hydrogène et un peu d'hélium,
mais surtout, les atomes n'existaient pas en tant que tels.
Prenons l'exemple de l'atome d'hydrogène,
normalement il est constitué d'un proton et d'un électron
qui lui est lié par la force electro-statique.
Mais cette association n'est possible
que s'il ne fait pas trop chaud.
On sait qu'au-dessus d'une certaine
température, à peu près 3000°C,
l'electron peut se retrouver arraché du proton.
Donc, à l'époque des premiers instants du Big Bang
on avait bien des électrons et des protons,
mais la température était tellement élevée
qu'ils étaient dissociés les uns des autres
pour former ce qu'on appelle un plasma, un plasma très chaud.
Une chose que vous savez sans doute c'est que,
quand la matière est chaude, elle émet des rayonnements.
C'est ce qui fait qu'une ampoule à incandescence brille
ou que des braises rougeoient
et le rayonnement émis va dépendre de la température.
Ça se voit très bien avec de l'acier qu'on forge,
au fur et à mesure qu'on le chauffe, il rougeoie
et plus sa température augmente, plus il devient
orange, jaune, et enfin, blanc.
A température ambiante, aussi, tous les objets
émettent de la lumière, mais dans les infrarouges
et il faut, par exemple, une caméra thermique
pour s'en rendre compte.
Tous ces rayonnements liés à la température,
on les appelle "rayonnement de corps noir".
Oui, même si la matière chauffée n'est justement PAS noire
A l'époque des premiers instants du Big Bang,
notre plasma primordial très chaud
émettait lui aussi un rayonnement de corps noir.
Sauf que, quand de la lumière se ballade dans un plasma,
elle ne peut pas vraiment le traverser
parce qu'elle interagit très fortement avec
les particules chargées, les protons, les électrons
et donc les photons qui composent
le rayonnement de corps noir
sont en permanence absorbés et diffusés dans le plasma.
Puisque les ondes lumineuses
ne pouvaient pas traverser le plasma,
on dit qu'à l'époque, la matière était "opaque".
Mais au bout d'un moment, il s'est passé un truc.
Au fur et à mesure que l'Univers s'étendait,
la densité et donc la température ont diminué
et quand celle-ci est passée sous le seuil d'à peu près 3000°C,
les électrons ont commencé à pouvoir s’associer
aux protons pour former des vrais atomes
et les atomes, eux, n’interagissent quasiment pas
avec les photons qui composent la lumière,
c'est-à-dire que, quand le plasma s'est transformé en atomes
et bien, soudainement, la matière est devenue transparente.
Les photons se sont donc mis à voyager
librement et à vivre leur vie
indépendamment de celle des atomes.
On appelle ce moment "le découplage".
On peut estimer quand il a eu lieu,
380 000 ans après l'hypothétique "naissance" de l'Univers
et ce rayonnement qui a été soudainement
libéré au moment du découplage
et bien, il devrait toujours être là.
En principe, l'Univers devrait être baigné d'une sorte de "lumière"
qu'on appelle parfois "le rayonnement fossile"
parce qu'il s'agit d'un vestige de ces premières
époques de l'histoire de l'Univers.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Alors, à quoi il peut bien ressembler ce rayonnement ?
Je vous ai dit qu'il a été émis à l'époque du découplage
quand la matière était environ à 3000°C.
3000°C c'est à peu près la température du filament
d'une ampoule à incandescence.
Donc, cette lumière fossile du Big Bang, elle devrait être
à peu près du même genre, une sorte de jaune clair.
Sauf que, quand je regarde dehors la nuit,
je ne vois pas une radiation jaune clair
qui baignerait tout le ciel.
La raison, c'est qu'il y a un élément
supplémentaire à prendre en compte,
c'est l’expansion de l'Univers.
On l'a dit, l’expansion de l'Univers tend à éloigner
tous les objets les uns des autres
et notamment à augmenter les distances entre les galaxies.
Et bien, sur cette lumière qui baigne l'Univers
depuis tout ce temps, elle a aussi un effet,
elle allonge les longueurs d'onde et donc
elle change la couleur du rayonnement.
Entre le moment du découplage et aujourd'hui,
on estime que l'Univers s'est dilaté d'un facteur environ 1000
et donc le rayonnement qui a été émis à l'époque
ne ressemble plus du tout à celui d'un corps à 3000°C,
mais plutôt à celui d'un corps à 3 K
c'est-à-dire 3°C au dessus du zéro absolu, -270°C.
La lumière émise par un corps aussi froid,
ce n'est plus de la lumière visible comme pour une lampe
ni même des infrarouges comme pour les corps
et les objets qui nous entourent.
Sur cette figure, vous voyez les spectres,
c'est-à-dire la composition en longueur d'onde
de la lumière émise par des corps à ces différentes températures.
Pour le soleil, dont la surface est à environ 6000°C,
c'est de la lumière visible et des infrarouges.
Pour une lampe à incandescence à 3000°C,
c'est pareil avec plus d'infrarouges.
Pour un objet à température ambiante (20°C),
c'est uniquement des infrarouges
Et pour un corps à 3 K (-270°C), il s'agit
principalement de rayonnement dit "micro-ondes",
"micro-ondes" est une appellation conventionnelle
qui veut dire que la longueur d'onde est, en gros, entre 1 mm et 1 m.
Dans le cas du rayonnement cosmologique,
le maximum est autour de 1 à 2mm.
Petite parenthèse : pourquoi est-ce qu'un four
micro-ondes s'appelle un four micro-ondes ?
C'est parce qu'il chauffe au moyen de rayonnements
dont la longueur d'onde est d'une dizaine de cm.
Bref, si on en croit cette théorie,
l'Univers devrait être baigné d'un rayonnement micro-onde
qui serait une sorte de reste, de fossile
de cette époque du découplage.
Alors je vous raconte tout ça comme si c'était évident,
mais ce raisonnement que je viens de vous décrire,
c'est seulement à la fin des années 40 que
des physiciens comme Alpher, Gamow et Herman
ont commencé à le faire.
Ils ont essayé de calculer la température correspondante
et il faut savoir que c'était une époque
où la théorie du Big Bang
était en compétition avec d'autres approches.
Entre 1948 et 1964,
plusieurs estimations de la température
du rayonnement cosmologique ont été faites
et elles se baladaient, en gros, entre 3 et 20 K .
En 1964, Robert Dicke, qui était à l'époque à Princeton,
décida de se lancer dans la construction d'un appareil de mesure
pour essayer de détecter ce fameux rayonnement cosmologique.
Au même moment, en mai 1964,
pas très loin de là, dans le New Jersey,
deux radio-astronomes, Penzias et Wilson,essayaient
de régler leur nouvelle antenne super-sensible.
Cette antenne avait été construite par les Bell Labs,
les laboratoires de recherche
de la compagnie de télécoms AT&T
et son but était d'étudier des communications
par rayonnements micro-ondes
entre la Terre et des sortes de ballons satellites.
Rien à voir avec de la cosmologie donc.
Mais ces deux radio-astronomes, Penzias et Wilson,
quand ils essayaient de régler leur antenne,
ils étaient en permanence gênés par un espèce de bruit de fond,
un peu comme quand on a
un bruit de friture sur un auto-radio.
[[ ♪ Bruit de friture ♪ ]]
Alors ils ont tenté d'éliminer toutes
les sources d'interférences possibles
et notamment, il se sont tapé un fastidieux
nettoyage de crottes de pigeons dans l'antenne.
Mais rien n'y a fait... impossible de se débarrasser du bruit.
Un bruit étrangement similaire à un rayonnement à 3 K.
Alors Penzias et Wilson n'étaient pas des cosmologistes
et donc, ils ne connaissaient pas
cette théorie du rayonnement fossile.
Mais au bout d'un moment, par bouche-à-oreille,
ils finirent par entendre parler des travaux
de Robert Dicke à Princeton.
Tous les trois se sont réunis, et ils ont réalisé
que ce que Penzias et Wilson venaient de découvrir,
c'était ce fameux rayonnement que Robert Dicke
avait calculé et essayait, lui, vainement de détecter.
Ils ont alors décidé de publier conjointement deux articles
relatant à la fois la découverte par Penzias et Wilson
et l'explication théorique par Dicke.
Et voilà ! On venait de mettre à jour
ce fameux rayonnement cosmologique,
ce vestige du passé chaud et dense de l'Univers
qui apportait une preuve décisive à la théorie du Big Bang.
Pour cette découverte qui restait malgré tout accidentelle,
Penzias et Wilson reçurent le prix Nobel en 1978,
mais RIEN pour Dicke, Alpher, Gamow et tous les autres
qui avaient quand même réussi l'exploit
de prédire le truc avant qu'on le découvre.
Autant dire les physiciens théoriciens avaient bien les boules...
Heureusement, 34 ans plus tard, ils ont été vengés.
Pour le Boson de Higgs, il s'est passé exactement
l'inverse, le Nobel est allé aux théoriciens
et rien pour ceux qui avaient fait l'expérience au CERN.
Un peu vache quand même...
♪ [Générique] ♪
Mais revenons à ce fameux rayonnement.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire ?
Suite à la découverte de Penzias et Wilson,
plusieurs expériences ont été lancées
pour essayer de mieux le mesurer et le caractériser.
Après quelques détections menées depuis le sol,
on décida finalement de lancer un satellite
pour aller le mesurer directement depuis l'espace.
Le satellite COBE, pour "COsmic Background Explorer".
Il faut savoir que ces mesures sont beaucoup
plus faciles à faire depuis l'espace.
Déjà, ça permet de s'affranchir d'un certain nombre de perturbations,
mais surtout, comme le satellite tourne autour de la Terre,
ça permet de mesurer le rayonnement
qui provient de toutes les directions du ciel.
COBE fut lancé en 1989
et ses premières mesures furent publiées au début des années 90.
Tout d'abord, elles confirmèrent que le rayonnement cosmologique
était bien un rayonnement de corps noir
et même, "le meilleur corps noir du monde".
Il faut savoir qu'un objet chauffé à une certaine température
n'émet jamais exactement un rayonnement de corps noir
qui colle parfaitement à la théorie,
mais dans le cas du rayonnement fossile, l'accord est parfait.
Ensuite, COBE a permis de préciser la température du rayonnement,
pas tout à fait 3 K mais 2,725 K, c'est précis.
En 1992, le satellite a révélé une information encore plus cruciale,
la température du rayonnement fossile
n'est pas exactement la même,
suivant la direction du ciel dans laquelle on regarde.
Elle varie, en gros, entre 2,725 et 2,726 K.
Ce n'est vraiment pas grand chose, c'est des variations
qui ne sont même pas de 1/1000ème de degré
et pourtant, on va voir que c'est capital.
Ces variations, c'est ce qu'on appelle
"Les anisotropies du rayonnement cosmologique"
et on les représente avec des cartes de ce genre.
Cette carte, c'est une carte du ciel.
Vous savez, de même qu'on peut représenter
la sphère terrestre sous forme d'un planisphère
et bien on fait la même chose avec la sphère céleste.
Cette ellipse représente le ciel au dessus de nos têtes.
Chaque point sur cette carte est une direction du ciel
et on symbolise avec un code couleur les variations de température
du rayonnement cosmologique par rapport à la moyenne.
Le rouge correspond à une direction
du ciel de laquelle nous parvient
un rayonnement légèrement plus chaud
et bleu, légèrement plus froid.
Suite à la mission COBE, d'autres satellites furent lancés
pour essayer d'améliorer la précision de ces mesures d'anisotropies.
Il y eut d'abord la mission WMAP, entre 2001 et 2010
et puis la mission européenne Planck qui s'est achevée en 2013,
mais dont, je crois, on n'a pas fini d'exploiter tous les résultats.
Ce que vous voyez ici, ce sont des cartes d'anisotropies
de plus en plus précises qui ont été obtenues.
Comme une photo qu'on aurait prise avec une meilleure résolution
et bien elles révèlent de plus en plus de détails,
elles nous apprennent plein de choses
sur les origines de l'Univers.
♪ Musique cosmique... ♫
Si vous pouviez vous balader et voir
le rayonnement micro-ondes avec vos yeux,
voilà à peu près ce que vous verriez...
♪ ♫ Musique cosmique...
Il faut savoir que ces anisotropies ne sont pas quelconques
et qu'elles sont prévues par la théorie du Big Bang.
On va voir comment on les analyse.
Commençons par un cas plus simple.
Imaginez une route avec des bosses
qui sont comme des fluctuations de sa hauteur.
On peut analyser l'intensité de ces fluctuations,
elles peuvent être plus ou moins fortes,
mais aussi leur longueur d'onde,
c'est-à-dire la longueur qui sépare deux pics.
Est-ce que c'est tous les mètres? Tous les 10cm ?
On peut aussi avoir des fluctuations qui sont
un mélange de plusieurs longueurs d'ondes, comme ici.
Pour caractériser ça, on calcule l'intensité
des fluctuations en fonction de leurs longueur d'onde.
Pour un mélange de fluctuations à 1m et à 10cm,
ça va ressembler à ça.
Pour ceux qui connaissent, techniquement, on fait une transformée de Fourrier,
comme quand on analyse les fréquences d'un son.
Revenons à la carte de température du rayonnement cosmologique.
Dans ce cas là, les fluctuations ne sont pas séparées
par une certaine longueur d'onde, comme sur une route,
mais par un certain angle dans le ciel.
On peut quand même faire le même genre d'analyse.
Imaginez quelque chose qui fluctue sur un cercle.
Les fluctuations se produisent avec une certaine "taille angulaire",
ici environ 60°, ce sont des fluctuations de grande échelle.
Et là 5°, donc à plus petite échelle.
Bien sûr, on peut avoir un mélange des deux
Et on peut faire le même genre de représentation,
l'intensité des fluctuations en fonction de leur taille angulaire.
Si je vous embête avec tous ces préliminaires un peu techniques,
c'est parce que si on fait ce genre d'analyse avec les
fluctuations de température du rayonnement cosmologique,
on obtient une courbe qui est, à mon sens,
une des plus belles et des plus importantes
de toute la physique fondamentale moderne.
C'est le spectre des fluctuations du rayonnement cosmologique
Alors comment on lit cette courbes ?
Et bien elle représente l'intensité des fluctuations
en fonction de la taille angulaire.
Ici, vous voyez un gros pic à environ 1°,
ça veut dire qu'il y a des fluctuations importantes
à des tailles angulaires de 1°
et ça correspond à tous ces petits grumeaux que vous voyez ici.
Ils font, en gros, 1/360ème de la largeur de l'image.
D'un grumeau, à son voisin, la température
a tendance à pas mal fluctuer
et c'est ce que ce pic reflète.
Les pics supérieurs correspondent
à des grumeaux qui sont plus fins
et qu'on distingue plus difficilement sur l'image,
mais qui montrent qu'on a d'autres fluctuations
à des échelles angulaires encore plus petites.
Alors pourquoi cette courbe est importante ?
Et bien parce qu'elle colle parfaitement
à la théorie du Big Bang
et qu'elle nous apprend une foule de choses
sur notre Univers et sa composition.
Ici vous voyez donc la courbe que l'on mesure,
par exemple avec les données de la mission Planck.
Si l'Univers avait une densité de matière
et d’énergie 20% plus élevée que ce qu'elle est,
la courbe serait différente, elle ressemblerait à ça...
Inversement, avec 20% en moins,
la courbe serait comme ça...
Vous voyez donc que l'allure et la position des pics,
nous renseigne sur la quantité
de matière contenue dans l'Univers,
mais aussi sur sa nature.
Si l'Univers ne contenait, ni matière noire,
ni énergie noire, que de la matière ordinaire
et bien la courbe serait comme ça...
Avec de la matière noire, mais pas d’énergie noire,
elle serait comme ça...
En utilisant des modèles et en cherchant les paramètres
qui permettent de reproduire exactement
la courbe que l'on observe,
on peut déterminer avec précision la composition
de l'Univers en masse et en énergie.
Environ 5% de matière ordinaire, 26% de matière noire
et 69% d’énergie noire.
Cette courbe, c'est comme un livre dans lequel on peut lire
les grands paramètres cosmologiques de la théorie du Big Bang.
C'est pas beau ça ?
Alors on entend parfois des gens
qui essaient de réfuter l'idée de Big Bang
en proposant des explications alternatives
notamment à l'expansion des galaxies.
Mais c'est oublier que LA meilleure preuve
expérimentale de la théorie du Big Bang,
c'est cette courbe incroyablement précise
et pour essayer de trouver une théorie alternative
qui reproduit cette courbe, vous pouvez vous levez tôt !
Aujourd’hui on n'a pas fini d'explorer tous les mystères
du rayonnement cosmologique,
Il y a notamment un autre type de fluctuations,
à part les fluctuations de température,
qui sont les fluctuations de polarisation
et on estime qu'elles pourraient
nous apprendre pas mal de choses
sur une lointaine époque primordiale de l'Univers :
ce qu'on appelle "L'inflation".
Il y a quelques années, il y avait eu des annonces
un peu prématurées à ce sujet
et en fait on attend toujours de confirmer ce qu'on
appelle les ondes gravitationnelles primordiales
qui sont des ondes gravitationnelles,
comme celles dont on a parlé récemment,
mais qui ce seraient produites au moment de l'inflation
et qui auraient laissé comme une "empreinte"
dans la polarisation du rayonnement cosmologique.
Enfin bon, jusqu'ici, on ne l'a toujours pas officiellement détecté...
Autre mystère, la carte actuelle du rayonnement
cosmologique fait apparaître une région bizarre:
"le point froid",
qui pourrait correspondre à une région
anormalement vide de l'Univers
qu'on appelle parfois "Le Super Vide".
Enfin, dernier aspect, on pense qu'en mesurant plus précisément
les fluctuations aux grandes échelles angulaires
qui aujourd'hui ont des barres d'erreurs assez grosses,
on pourra apprendre plein de choses
sur des phénomènes de gravité quantique
qui se seraient produits au tout premiers instants de l'univers.
Notamment dans la théorie de la gravité quantique à boucle, dont j'avais parlé dans un épisode précédent.
Abbay Ashtekar et Aurélien Barrau ont montré que la cosmologie quantique à boucles
prédit les déviations dans les fluctuations par rapport au scénario classique
Mais avec les données actuelles, bah, les erreurs de mesures sont encore trop grandes pour faire la distinction.
A ce jour, plusieurs nouvelles missions sont à l'étude et elles devraient permettre de mesurer avec encore plus de précision ce rayonnement cosmologique
Et on finira peut-être par avoir les réponses à toutes ces questions.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo ! Comme d'hab, n'hésitez pas à partager, liker, vous abonner, la cloche tout ça...
Si ça vous intéresse, vous pouvez aller jeter un oeil à mon deuxième livre
qui vient de sortir et qui s'appelle " Insoluble mais vrai"
Si vous voulez des news de la chaine, vous pouvez en trouver sur Facebook et  sur Twitter
et ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipee. Merci à bientôt !
♫ [[ Musique générique de fin ]] ♪